all right Mr Unity is back just in case
you missed him President Biden delivered
a Christmas message from the White House
calling for peace and claiming his
concerned that America has become too
divided take a look
I sincerely hope this Holloway had this
holiday season will drain the poison
that has infected our politics and set
us against one another
I hope this Christmas season marks a
fresh start for our nation
because there's so much that unites us
As Americans
so much more that unites us than devises
us our politics has gotten so angry so
mean so partisan
and too often we see each other's
enemies not as neighbors as Democrats
Republicans not as fellow Americans
we become too divided but Biden must
have forgotten the past year where he
fueled that division by calling
Republicans a threat to democracy
this ain't your father's Republican
party this is a Maga party now let me
tell you about this Ultra Magna agenda
it's extreme as most Maga things are
because this Mega crowd is really the
most extreme political organization
that's existed in American history
American Republicans don't just threaten
our personal rights and Economic
Security
they're a threat to our very democracy
the extreme set of Maggie Republicans
has chosen to go backwards full of anger
violence hate and Division
judge I mean this is unbelievable that
the president is coming out with a
Christmas message which by the way I'm
all about Christmas messages but I mean
the fact that he's talking about
draining the poison hasn't Joe Biden
been the poison in politics over the
last two years you know I think that the
American people were so optimistic when
he came into office that he would be the
unifier he would be as he called himself
the adult in the room the truth is that
the hypocrisy in this is so potent it is
so rich you know for the man who was
talking about this phony Unity rhetoric
now I mean he called half of Americans
uh the Maga Republicans who voted for
Donald Trump who was 73 74 million were
extremists we're semi-fascists we're the
people who are creating this threat to
democracy I mean he's calling half of
America that but the the the he he says
that we live in the lies in the shadow
of lies that we don't know the light of
Truth he's almost like he's this this
like somebody open who's telling us that
you were condemned for life and he wants
a little kindness you know what Mr
President if you want some kindness
maybe you ought to extend it to those
people are coming through the Border who
are dying on the way in freezing
sleeping on the streets don't have a
blanket you're letting them in with the
open borders you're fighting to keep the
borders open fighting in the Supreme
Court fighting in Arizona so they take
those containers down and he talks about
draining the poison he's the one who
sets us against each other he's the one
who's doing this and he says fellow
human beings need to be treated with
dignity well how about you treat us with
dignity it's just it's just too rich and
the unvaccinated are stupid sobs right
and but it means so Jessica it's
interesting because I want to go to you
on this I mean are we being too mean at
Christmas should we give him that Olive
Branch to go okay Mr President you're
going to change your ways over the next
two years Merry Christmas and let
bygones be bygones I mean sure
it would be nice but partisans are
partisans and every president is going
to make a Christmas address it sounds
like that right or they should and every
president wants to win elections and
right now you're winning elections by
isolating a group on the other side and
it's not as broad as you're making out
to be he doesn't actually think that
you're a threat to the Republic he's
talking about people who deny election
results in fact like Kerry Lake and
Steve Bannon are still walking around
saying that she's the governor-elect if
that was true how does Kareem
Jean-Pierre have a job she denied the
2016 election she said it was stolen I I
think it's pretty different when he's
talking about people who came to the
Capitol on January 6th and ran around
there and we all know what happened and
specify he did he was like I am talking
he clarified so many times it it bored
me by the end he was dividing the
country now he's like we're all peace
and love everybody at Christmas and I
think that that is total hypocrisy
but Katie I want to go to you on this
because what I think I'm sorry I'm
shutting down we don't have a whole lot
of time Merry Christmas
um happy holidays
my thought is that as as Joe Biden sees
on January 3rd Republicans are going to
take over the Congress he's like well
listen they might investigate me and
Hunter and our Shady business dealings
maybe I have to make peace before they
take over I think it sounds a lot like
he's running in 2024. we know that he's
discussing this with his family over the
Christmas holiday I actually agree with
Jessica you know I wish that presidents
would just make statements about
Christmas and the season and what
Christmas or Hanukkah or whatever
holiday is all about rather than
injecting the politics into it and being
dishonest about well you know we have
poison in our politics and we should
treat everybody with respect that is
what he ran on in 2020 it was a lie it's
not true he is one of the most abusive
presidents we've had in modern history
he did say that for the vaccinated we
are looking at a winter of severe
illness and death that was a lie but
politics is a blood sport so just keep
the Christmas message about Christmas
talk about that and then be honest about
the fact that it's tough to deal with
Republicans Democrats and there are very
divided interest in this country
depending on which party you're right do
you agree with that Jessica I do I think
we're echoing the same sentiment about
this and I people should just call a
spade a spade and know the difference
between a Christmas message and a speech
that you're making when you're heading
into a hotly contested midterms they're
going to be vastly different and this
was both right he was talking
politicians
saying take politics out of your
Christmas dinner is not talking about
politics he's not saying like and by the
way I hate Mitch McConnell he just said
go have a turkey if any poisons been
injected into our politics as if he has
nothing to do with that and as a
Democrats don't have anything to do with
that when they absolutely do based on
their rhetoric and things that Joe Biden
has said Do me a fairly your take I mean
if you wanted to end the divisiveness
and the politics this was a year where
you would just cut Joe Biden's mic
because he did say a lot of divisive
things I actually don't think he hates
Mitch McConnell I know you were kidding
but Mitch McConnell's outspending
anybody in the Democratic party right
now
our Supreme Court did he well then hey
but this is who Biden is Biden is the
Tony Clifton of politics there was an
old Andy Kaufman character he would come
on stage as his alter ego and he'd be
like all right folks this is a no
smoking club before the show starts then
he would light a cigar and do his and
everybody like the nerve of this guy and
that's Biden he's like all right we need
Unity but the Border agents are whipping
Haitian migrants not true pandemic of
the unvaccinated it's Jim Crow on
steroids in Georgia and that's the thing
Joe Biden lecturing us on Unity is like
Johnny Depp and Amber Heard lecturing us
on civility okay no one's buying it even
if they promise to forgive the loan down
the road no way no one is about it I
totally agree with that all right good
discussion hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else